hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
uh this discussion of The Last of Us
episode three that is Natalie who uh
Natalie who are you what do you do
uh my name is Natalie Abrams and I
co-created the show Gotham Knights and
Jackson who is below me right now
Jackson who are you what do you do hi uh
my name is Jackson McHenry and I am a
senior writer for vulture thank you both
for joining me um I was intending to do
this like discussion loss of this
episode thing every Monday night but
when I saw this episode I was like oh I
need to pick these people like I was
like let me try and make this one
slightly more interesting
um by what I've done here is pick
somebody who loved it Natalie and
somebody who didn't like it so much
Jackson I also really liked it sorry
Jackson
um but it's definitely not at all what I
was expecting have both of you played
the game
certainly very different to what
actually happens in The Last of Us so
unpredictable
um it's
I I thought it was a beautiful emotional
story that broke my heart so so so fast
but um definitely subverted expectations
which is why I think this one's a really
interesting one to talk about so uh
Jackson you want to give us like just
vague
overall how you felt about the episode
or how you received it uh yeah I mean I
think it was interesting for me because
it is it is sort of the major deviation
from the game
um and you get this whole storyline
about Mick offerman's Bill and Murray
Bartlett's Frank sort of filling in
their past their relationship him being
a survivalist and then sort of slowly
opening up over time
um and I I just would like to say hi I'm
all for expanding the storyline doing
something different on TV and
um also having wonderful gay love
stories and everything and I just I was
ended up being frustrated on my end and
just sort of it felt a little cliched in
the moves it was doing in terms of other
stories that have been told on
television
um in this genre of sort of having
um that's very similar to something that
might be told on say station 11 or
um leftovers
um this kind of move of like we're gonna
tell this love story and and I wish that
their characters it's a long episode I
wish that there was sort of more depth
and complexity to it
um which ended up being frustrating
um but I'm happy for all the people who
loved it yeah for sure and yeah that's
we're not trying to argue against people
feeling differently so I guess uh you've
listed shows that I have not seen I know
I need to watch The Leftovers I know I
do
um so part of the the frustration is
that you felt like it was rehash and I
guess I can see that there isn't like
necessarily a lot of depth to Frank's
character so much
um in effort to tell the Love Story
quite quickly uh so your your thought
there is you preferred to have seen more
depth to the the characters ultimately
yeah and I think there's a little bit of
you sort of get the setup of one is sort
of on the defensive and a Survivor and
one is a little bit more open and he's
more physically fit and that sort of
changes over time but you can sort of
see the Arc of where it's going
um once they start to meet and get to
know each other
um and I I maybe this is also I I think
you know there could be a little bit
more humor to it there could be a little
bit more just sort of them as as
characters
um a lot of the sort of dialogue is is
pretty I mean because it is short I
think you know pretty straight to the
point
um and I just wanted a little bit more
sort of color or Grace notes some sort
of surviving deviation there's a little
bit of there's a moment where they sort
of he reveals that he's planted the
strawberries and they sort of are like
bickering over the fact they've created
for the seeds and then they're sharing
them
um and I sort of like that's great but
is there a way to add more complexity to
to expand on these characters to make us
feel a little bit more
um I also have to say with the leftovers
and they they sort of later on in the
episode in the big sort of moment of
um they're sharing the last dinner they
use on the nature of daylight which is a
beautiful song by Max Richter or piece
by Max Richter but it's also been used
in a lot of other instances is it the
song that was in arrival I think it yes
it is okay that's I was like
um yes and it's it's it I think it's one
of the reasons why arrival score was not
nominated for
um best score because it was not
entirely original
um and so that's just a moment where I'm
like yes I is this lovely emotional
piece but I've seen it in many other
things and maybe it's a problem of me
having seen too many things sort of one
on it I was like is there something else
you could have used is there a way to
sort of do this differently and and more
and with sort of um to take the uh
opportunity to try something else I
believe was also the creators have said
it was the temp track that they just
were like well this is working well so
we're using it oh wow
and I think it would have been
interesting to try to come up with your
own thing um yeah
so I I guess your feeling seems to be
that you felt like it was a bit cliche
yes yeah looking short um so Natalie
conversely how did you feel about the
episode yeah it's really interesting to
hear that take Jackson because you know
as somebody who I just love uh the games
so much
um that that you're one of your Chief
sort of
not complaints I guess
um but you know perspectives is that uh
you you wish it went deeper and to me
I'm like we never got any of this at all
in the game this was entirely brand new
in a sense we got just a little tidbit
we didn't even they didn't confirm
yeah well they confirmed he was gay with
the their gay porn references but even
then it's kind of jokey in a way that's
sort of weird now yeah no it was it was
just hinted at and and you know I was
reading it one of the uh you know
creators interviews and they were saying
like they could only they couldn't be
explicit about it because it would have
been rejected basically oh wow and and
so I was like yeah that makes sense I
get it but to have this then to have
this episode
um the freedom to be able to like tell
this story of like true connection that
even when life looks the most bleed week
there are still stories of Hope out
there and I feel like
I don't know I just feel like we've
we've had all of the zombie shows before
we've had our fair share of fear and
tension you know of the unknown of jump
scares for entertainment's sake but this
sort of
haunting Love Story provided I think
more tension than some you know battle
with bloaters in in the high school gym
in that chapter you know of the game
um so to me you know I I don't know I
just I really felt it was a nuanced
story I too have not uh you know
finished leftovers I haven't watched
station 11 so you know maybe it's
because I haven't uh had that exposure
that I'm like I don't really like this
story it was really touching look my
reference point was up I was like oh
it's like up and I did think that
um it's not like that didn't occur to me
while I was watching it um and I do
agree like it we definitely get some
more Nuance from Bill if I'm trying to
see it from jacket's perspective
um we could have had a little bit more
of an arc there were some moments of
nuance that I really liked like I love
the line of uh some of my worst days
have been with you I think you said that
it's not painted as this beautiful love
story that I think also really happens
in gay representation specifically in
media that it's not completely perfect
and that is one thing that I'm glad they
still kept bill as a bit of a [__] bag
like he still sucks a bit we're seeing
the softest side of this man versus what
we've ever seen in the games but he's
still kind of jerky he's still
effectively a conspiracy theorist I
don't really like I don't know where you
put him in
um still kind of sucks but I guess you
know we could have seen a little bit
more
of an arc and I I didn't find it
predictable in that I didn't know what
was going to happen and having played
the game I found that actually to be
super exciting even when they have the
wine of like being like he's probably
gonna kill himself is he gonna kill
himself like thinking that he probably
would but I wasn't sure if he would I
found really cool having played the
games to be like oh it's fun that I
don't actually know what the outcome of
this is going to be and I think the
thing that we lost to your point Natalie
is stuff that is really cool for a
zombie show but a little bit less
interesting for a TV show that's about
the last of us which I think is about
love and relationships and people
growing together because the alternative
is like they go to the school and they
shoot someone upside down and the blow
to all of that stuff's cool and I would
have loved to have seen it but I don't
know that it pushes the story
further in the way that I felt like this
did and reflected you know
tests and the loss of tests and it's
like an episode for us to deal with
death and also pushing forward the
parallels between their relationship and
the relationship between Joel and Ellie
like I I saw those themes in there but
maybe I was looking too hard so Jackson
my question would be like if we didn't
would you suggest that you you'd have
preferred they did something else with
this episode or just they do this one
thing differently
I would I it would be more the the to do
this thing and did you just do it more
deeply would be sort of the kind of
thing that I would want and and sort of
having seen sort of a little bit further
on and just because they sent out sort
of more no spoilers
um it's just a sensation of like a lot
of the show is such a one-to-one
recreation of the game which is I think
what what people want and sort of in a
sense but I I sort of was like I wish
there was actually kind of more of this
kind of thing executed with more depth
and complexity that like it feels like
it kind of returns to the railroad
tracks of a lot of the game at least no
spoilers but anyway
um and and it sort of was like if you're
taking you know
the opportunity to do this throw more at
the audience in a way and sort of you
have the chance to sort of have all this
sort of production value on the show and
it just felt a little bit like it was
like we're doing this which is wonderful
but we're following back on tropes in
this moment
um why not push it further
um I guess if we had seen bill after
Frank had died uh that would have been
slightly more
complex
um and I guess you still could have told
the Joel with Ellie you still could have
imparted the knowledge on them but
I don't know dude it just broke my heart
so much that I was just like oh my God
actually I guess
yeah I'm glad that you know Bill and
Ellie didn't meet in the show like I did
miss some of their fun kind of like
one-liners at each other of course but
like to see the man Bill had become now
having loved and Been Loved like it just
wouldn't have felt right and so that's
where I kind of disagree with you Awana
like I think Bill did have an arc he
could not I don't like one I don't think
he ever would have come out had the
pandemic not happen but two he he says
it himself in his letter like to Joel
that he's like I hated everyone in this
world and I was glad when they died and
then he found his purpose he found his
person to fight for to protect like even
yes he still hung on to some of these
not great ideologies but he still was
able to open himself up to the
possibility of love to the point where
you know I I like paused uh the TV e on
the letter you know when it zooms in on
on you know to you know protect tests
um and the rest of the letter it's it's
kind of blurry but I think he's
basically like telling
uh Joel what food pairs well with wine
and and in that moment I was like oh my
gosh he is imparting his last words were
literally imparting this wisdom to Joel
about like
yeah worked for him for love and he's
saying to Joel like open yourself up to
essentially maybe you'll get to have my
Same Love Story
yeah and I just thought that was so
touching you know yeah I think it's not
I'm not definitely not saying he had no
walk it's more that just like the didn't
like anyone is the very beginning
and then he's in love so I don't feel
like the love was necessarily a journey
right like it hap that happens pretty
quickly
um we cut from I think them having sex
and then straight to them arguing on the
street which I loved the choice of doing
that like that's such a like a a good
reality of relationships and how they
probably do exist like that even in
those circumstances I mean it's not
quite the same but we went through a
pandemic I'm sure we were all in houses
with people we love for way too long and
that kind of it certainly happened like
it's it's rough and it's definitely the
lens of the show is a little bit
different I think after you know having
been through a pandemic which is super
interesting but I just don't feel like
from the point where you know that he's
in love that there's a huge Arc other
than death
um which again I still felt positively
about and I did feel to to me as though
it is the episode is like the thesis of
what the last of us is sort of
exemplified and again I don't know if
I'm just reading too much into it
because of who I am as a person but I
was like I I do feel like this this was
the closure for how sudden and brutal
Tess's death is is that this is drawn
out and is an episode about somebody
dealing with somebody they love dying
even if it still happens pretty quickly
but like the choices that led to that
the I think decision to not
uh trade for medication or not even try
to get medication is partly on bill
because he didn't want anyone in the
outside world like some of that
complexity um
is there so I don't know that I feel
like I'm repeating myself um but I did
also want to take the time to ask do
either of you have an opinion because I
do not have one that I feel is informed
or very strong on
if if this breaches the kelio gays trip
that's so interesting because I I
literally was thinking about that as I
watched it and I was like oh
I don't think it does like honestly
because usually the the barrier gaze
Trope is showing someone's motivation
for one of them right yeah well not just
that but it's like the immediate moment
after happiness
um uh and usually it's like sex or kiss
or something like that then one of them
is is killed and so you know that was so
tough obviously like on Buffy uh you
know the hundred all that kind of stuff
um but I didn't feel it here because it
wasn't like the first time Bill and
Frank had sex then one of them died it
was they had a long
Love Story
um that you know is even I guess more
beautiful in hindsight when you think
about
it was 2003 when the you know cordyceps
pandemic like broke out gay marriage
wasn't even legalized when the world
fell apart that's true
and so they that was like one of their
last acts was to get married and I was
just like God like it's like the little
things that like for me I felt like
there was Nuance to it so I will say I
found it very funny that initially
um
Frank's wig is so bad like his wig is
really bad for a show that has such
amazing production value they fully
built this whole town the whole town was
built except for the roofs his wig is so
bad and I was like well that means he's
gonna grow older because I was like well
they put a wig on him to age him down
and they're gonna take the [__]
terrible wig off I don't know how that
happened
it's not your mama uh it happens uh yeah
Jackson wig maker is 10 miles is it
actually Alberta um yeah I have to say
being in a tour of like over dinner
looked great like it seemed like it was
nice to see her back yeah she seemed
happy yeah I mean like I think it's sort
of like it's definitely on your mind the
fact that you're you know you know that
these two gay characters are going to
not but everyone is going to die and you
know I mean everyone's going to die but
like this is a world where most people
are dying because it is you know a full
on apocalypse situation
um so yeah I mean I think there's like a
little bit of sort of
discomfort of you a a little bit of like
oh it's so sweet and you're in in the
one hand you're both like is it
patronizing that it's you're you're
using this storyline to add the
emotional effect or is it sort of
serious and sure
um I don't know that sort of mixes in my
mind sometimes but that's sort of often
a reaction to these sorts of things on
like a major Network show you we're like
well they're not the main characters but
they are getting the time and how does
that balance work out and do you feel
um but my my sort of objective of the
episode were more about the sort of like
like you were saying there's a lot of
things that you can kind of
read into and imagine about sort of Bill
as a character and and Frank to fill in
to figure out what the story is but I
sort of wanted to actually kind of get
see the actors play more of that and
play more you know what what the
frustrations are if they're sort of more
than just bickering I imagine you know a
long serious relationship like this
there's a lot more than just the kinds
of fights that you see and a lot more
going on and that was more that I wanted
it wasn't necessarily sort of a barrier
gaze kind of objective yeah sure yeah I
haven't actually seen anybody have the
barrier gaze objection I was just
something that occurred to me I was like
technically they broke a rule here but
it doesn't feel like they did which I
guess is it felt entirely respectful and
and purposeful but that was one of my
things with episode two actually was
that I do wish we had seen a little bit
more of the relationship between Tess
and Joel and I think the pacing is like
definitely a challenge with this is uh I
at least believed that Tess and Joel
loved each other more than I think I did
playing the game uh where the game I was
like I recognize you're in a
relationship and you have each other's
backs but I never like saw All That Much
Chemistry where I felt I saw more of
that in the show and then when it
happened I was like I wish we'd had
tests for a little bit longer and I had
the same just a little bit more Nuance
to test and I would have liked to see
more of that and I guess yeah Jackson
your takeaway of this episode is
essentially the same
um but I think
like if it had been longer
that almost seems impossible
um your suggestion would have to be that
like they approached this chunk of time
differently right that yeah more more
none if they're longer or more time
spent with more more sort of
yeah just in sort of more refined scenes
in writing and and sort of the fights
that we see feel fairly insubstantial
and sort of the arc that we're given is
so much like guardedness to opening up
that it feels like there could be more
beats to be hit um and I also just think
it because it it's there there have been
other shows that have been in this
territory that have done similar things
that I sort of fall back to like
something like station 11 which everyone
should go watch and if you have HBO to
watch Last of Us
um but that is a show of a lot that has
has sort of scenes of episodes and a lot
about like similar to the sort of wine
pairing thing the question of how do you
carry on with what civilization is and
and those characters to me felt like
they had they were more alive than than
Bill and Frank got to be
um and sort of more complicated uh how
did you feel about the the letter at the
end did you feel like that was was
purposeful like what was your take away
from from what he left Joel with yeah it
felt purposeful it felt it felt to me a
little bit like sort of the you know it
it it wanted more I I would have loved
to you know to to get into you know you
see the wine pairings but to get into a
little bit more of that and to get into
sort of I like that it wasn't just
straight up like I had a great love in
this thing I like there was a little bit
more of grumpiness in that but I almost
wanted him to be more grumpy or more
spiky
um but uh I also like you know the Linda
Ronstadt thing is is fairly telegraphed
and happy very happy for Linda Ronstadt
to have this moment
um but but it felt like there could be a
just more coloring more
um more depth and
I just more than anything really
appreciated that the the letter Bill
wrote Joel is is like a soft play on
Frank's devastating suicide letter from
the game and sort of saying you know
Bill never liked Joel but he also it's
so clear that he like respected the hell
out of him and leaves him with such
um
like peaceful parting words that kind of
feel like that first step toward Joel
being able to care about Ellie you know
um and so that's I was I was sort of
like she's so rude in this episode dude
like I I keep talking about this and
everyone's disagreeing with me
um maybe it's just that I was like when
I was at her age I was like even more
passive than I am now that she when Tess
dies she has zero sympathy or expresses
zero sympathy at all and I get that she
blames herself and is being defensive
but it's it's just very very different
to the game at this point where I think
we care a lot more about Ellie and I
think that we have to because it's a
video game we have to protect her and
she has to give us stuff but
Ellie's real mean she's real me I think
the thing that we have to like remember
while watching Ellie is that she was
born post outbreak sure and so she has
lived a life where she's used to losing
everyone like she has never had anyone
to sort of hold on to although when they
show Ashley Johnson playing her mother
I'm totally gonna lose it
um haven't you know watched uh my my
wife's screeners because I would never
do that but uh but I you know read on
Hollywood Reporter that she was coming
in and I was so
um oh oh cool yeah I hadn't realized but
um uh so she's never really had anything
to attach to to hold on to and and we
get that that sense in little moments
when she's like oh I've never been in
the woods I've never seen bugs I've
never been in a car she doesn't even
know how to put on a seat belt you know
stuff like that where you're like oh
she's just a kid and she's a kid who
like many people
um use this like comedy and and you know
as a defense mechanism you know
basically like or like self-deprecation
like just being like you said she puts
up these walls because if she thought
for even a second I am
to blame for for Tess's death it would
consume her yeah like and so she has to
be snarky she has to put up a wall
because otherwise she would just be
consumed by feeling responsible for
everything that's gone on around her
yeah I mean in the game
she says Hey Joel I'm sorry about Tess
and I don't remember what he says back
but uh obviously This Time It's
Different in the in the show Joel
says don't apologize and she's like I
wasn't going to so they are they're very
different points uh but I suspect again
in a game you have to be attached sooner
because you actually have to personally
quote unquote escort this person and I
think that we'll probably see more of an
arc from her but directly related to the
harshness of Ellie and I do think this
version of Ellie is different um how did
either of you feel about her choosing to
like
scalpel open the face of a clicker
it was an interesting one
um well I mean I think to like that
point about Ellie is it's also it's an
interesting challenge for a show to take
something where there's so much like
ambient dialogue in the game where you
get to know a character just through
like as you're doing a mission just sort
of the two people talking where you have
to just like get it's harder for the
show to get that much more information
um so like I can't I do I think belly
Bella Ramsey is a really interesting
actor uh and like I like the sort of
that this take on Ellie um as a little
bit sort of gruffer and more intense but
it maybe it is just a sort of more of a
challenge to
um viewers to not have as much time with
Ellie too
be familiar and just you're like oh
she's going for it yeah
Matt how about you I I you know what the
clicker thing to me spoke to this
is gonna be a weird way to to word it
but it's like that childlike innocence
of like you are when you're a kid you're
still discovering things and you're
you're TR you learn lessons you know the
hard way of like tripping and falling
and now when you're an adult you trip
and fall you break your face and so like
I think she is still discovering life in
a sense and so that felt like an
exploratory moment
um for her to like be like what is going
on underneath the surface and I would
never have this experience of being able
to do this unless a clicker was
literally pinned right here
um and so there's the Curiosity of like
what is what is not happening under my
skin
um that has now happened to so many
millions of other people sure yeah when
I asked um Troy Baker about it he said
that the the idea behind that is that
she is violent is that this version of
Ellie is violent and you know when Joel
like beats the [__] out of the guy who
uh sees her positive test
Ellie's supposed to look at that in a
way that's like oh cool
um which I think is a very interesting
departure from Ellie and that's I just
think the awk has to be different in a
TV show which it finally it's so funny
that this show is actually the same
length as the game it is the same amount
of hours but things do have to be
delivered in such a different way
because we don't have that inherent
empathy um that that comes with trying
to like feel like you're the protector
up a little go are you sure it's the
same amount of hours because you know it
took me probably like six or seven hours
to beat that first bloater so I don't
know about your timeline here the the
first I'm playing through the game at
the same time as playing as watching the
show and I'm like stopping the game when
I get to the end of an episode so the
end of the bill section I think is like
five hours in so it's a little bit
longer but not by a ton
um it get good it's basically what I'm
trying to say they're not you just gotta
get good that's a you problem skill
issue running the game
okay it seems like a skill issue yeah I
don't know that you need to put that on
me wow talk to me again when you get to
the Rat King and you let me know how
long that takes you the the one in part
two in the hospital the Rat King died is
that called the Rat King yes it's called
the Rat King because basically when a
bunch of rats are in an enclosed space
their tails can accidentally get tied
together and they become one sort of
being and so the idea is that the Rat
King is a bunch of different infected
that are all intertwined terrifying each
other hated it yeah um in a great way
though uh so the only other thing that I
really felt like I wanted to touch on
for this episode is I did have one
question which is
um what do you guys think the narrative
purpose of seeing Bill get shot was I
think in at least in my perspective I
feel like it served um several purposes
one uh to show how far he'd go to
protect his love
to uh to to your point of him saying you
know um it wasn't really get Joel it was
more Joel will take care like he he
thought in this moment he was gonna die
and thanks to Frank going behind his
back and making a friend on the on the
CV radio basically he was like oh
I have someone now I trust explicitly to
take care of my love if I cannot do it
myself and so I thought that was a
really big character moment because it
was showing that he had trusted outside
of
his little circle of himself and Frank
he trusted Joel so explicitly at that
point in in their relationship that he
was like he will take care of my partner
Jackson do you have any thoughts on that
yeah like and I think there's a lot of
like sort of the Arc of like Bill going
from someone who's like I can't depend
on they wanted to show it I can't depend
on anyone else too there are people that
I might you know
would trust me any sort of effort maybe
just only an extremity and then
more willing and further on yeah okay
we've probably had the same read on that
then I don't feel so lost um the only
other thing is I kind of wanted to ask
for before I let you both go is is how
you felt about like because I thought
this was very cool and a very
interesting additive to the world in a
different perspective of just seeing how
we set the traps up seeing how the
Raiders responded because we did see
like quite a few minutes of that in this
episode you know you see him go to the
supermarket effectively that is like a
very quick cut in this episode and then
seeing him set everything up and setting
up this town like I thought that painted
a very good picture of a very different
perspective for anyone who might have
questions who's never played the games
of what life outside of accusing can be
like for people who live in aren't just
Raiders like I thought it was really
really neat um did anyone have any
alternate takes on any of those moments
in this episode
no I like that I think I think I mean I
think one of the sort of things with the
show is you know give a limited amount
of time and
um just to getting more getting to see
that and figuring out how to incorporate
the things that you learn ambiently
playing a game into the storyline
um is tough and we don't have all those
notes
you can't exactly you can't just like
click you you know and there's not sort
of the scaling of one player who might
click on everything and one player who
might just play through the game like
you you have to show the audience the
whole thing so yeah I personally like I
I love that the show has done such a
great job of sort of expanding the world
outside of just Joel and Ellie like
getting getting to see those little
moments of him showing up to Home Depot
uh even you know going back to episodes
one and two with like the little pieces
on different parts of the world you know
and how they were reacting to to the
outbreak
um and so to have I don't know it sort
of felt like when Joel got to the car
and you had the the battery pieces set
out it sort of felt like you know you
were crafting you know yeah just like
you do in the game so that was kind of
exciting to me
um to really like feel that moment and
so it's like in an episode where you
have
something like setting up an apocalypse
you know City bunker kind of thing you
also have something like the the
the window
yeah you know the window at the end
which is such a a beautiful Tribute to
The Game's load load screen and I I'm
like I don't have any tattoos but I'm
like do I get it do I get an open window
tattoo I don't know that would be pretty
cool yeah
um I think that
the there's some arguments about like oh
wasted Bill what about all these cool
moments and ultimately in the game while
I do think again I'm I'm it's a bummer
to miss out some of those Joel and sorry
Ellie and Bill moments um
he is ultimately a guy who just takes
them somewhere to get a car battery I
think this is this is a bit more uh
potent and to that point like I gotta be
honest I'm glad they didn't stay true to
the game for that because I think all
we're all already miserable in our own
piece of the pandemic like in our own
dreary Real World
um like what would it have served to
remind us that there is no hope for like
change or betterment or or whatever it's
like that bill and Frank had this you
know dysfunctional functional you know
relationship says it all like as you
said at the beginning of our chat you
know it wasn't perfect they had bad days
but that's every marriage that's every
friendship that's every relationship but
the key is not giving up just as it's
the key to life it's the key to survival
the thesis it's a franchise I think yeah
just don't give up have faith in people
uh which is well beautiful and uh that
is all we have time for thank you both
for joining me Natalie where can people
find you
uh I'm on Twitter and Instagram both uh
at Natalie Abrams anything cool you've
got coming up soon that people should
keep an eye on oh you know a little show
called Gotham Knights debuting a Tuesday
March 14th on the CW after uh Superman
and Lois good luck uh Jackson how about
you where can people find you uh you can
find me on Twitter at uh mchenryjd I'm
not a lawyer is my initials
I bet you have to clarify that a lot is
there anything some people are like how
dare you go to law school and then do
this
I don't I didn't go to law school that's
sorry about my initials man that's
amazing um do you have anything that you
want to give a shout out to that you're
walking on right now
um oh I'm working on a oral history of a
show from about a decade ago cool uh
that we are with my co-worker Catherine
that we are very excited about so
hopefully people will get to see more of
that soon um awesome I can't see what it
is yet all right well we will stay tuned
I'll leave links in the description to
where you can find both Natalie and
Jackson and thank you for watching
Everybody I'll see you next time bye
thank you